in today's morning rounds a new virus
that has killed nine people and infected
hundreds more in China has now spread to
the US a man in his 30s from Washington
state is the first person in America to
be diagnosed with corona virus it's
called the man returned to the Seattle
area last week from a trip to Wuhan
that's a city in central China where the
outbreak began right now that patient is
in isolation in a hospital north of
Seattle our number-one priority is to
complete the identification of all the
patients contacts reach out to the
contacts and monitor their health we
also want to make enhanced screening is
already in place at three US airports
with two more being added this week our
doctor Tara Narula is here at the table
with more on this story you hear about
it you see the mask it's very disturbing
how worried should we be yeah and what
is it exactly so this is a form of a
corona virus we've known about Crona
viruses before this is a new strain this
is a virus that's found worldwide it
causes typically a mild or moderate
respiratory illness but it can be more
severe we saw that with stars and MERS
which are also forms of corona virus so
certainly the CDC is recommending that
we be cautious about this that we'd be
proactive because it is a new strain it
is contagious so interestingly they
think it does circulate in animals and
occasionally it can make the jump from
animals to humans which is what they
think happened in this case because the
initial cases were surrounding an area a
market a seafood animal market in the
wuhan area and there so they think that
it started in animals it was transmitted
to humans and now they're saying that in
fact it is spread between human to
humans and there's no vaccine right now
so how are people being treated there's
no vaccine the NIH is doing research to
develop a vaccine but that's a ways away
and so it's really supportive care at
this point which means you know fluids
rest pain medications medicines to lower
fever temperature how our health
officials tracking the spread of this
virus how are they looking for people
who may be infected well certainly with
this case they've sent you know a team
to Washington and they're doing a
traceback where they're looking at
everyone that this gentleman may have
come in contact with back in China on
the plane in the United States and they
have activated kind of their emergency
operations they're also in communication
with the whu-oh which is convening a
meeting today
to decide whether they're gonna declare
this a worldwide public health we see
these pictures of people wearing though
the kind of the masks out in public do
those do anything to prevent infection
well certainly we think that this is
spread by droplets so you know airborne
precautions like wearing a mask can help
also if you touch a surface kind of like
the flu it can be spread that way so
hand-washing disinfection
what are the symptoms Tara so it can be
anything from fever to cough respiratory
difficulties shortness of breath muscle
aches it can progress to pneumonia and
you know there have been some deaths
although the deaths that have occurred
have been in those who are older than 60
and also seemed to have underlying
medical conditions so I think the big
message here is not to panic the CDC is
saying that at this point the risk to
the general public is low so if you
haven't been to China or haven't been in
contact with somebody who's been to
China do you have reason to be concerned
I think the CDC is saying again the risk
is low so they said for any one kind of
sitting around there a dinner table this
is not something that you have to be
worried about but certainly because it
is a new strain and people don't have
immunity to it and strains can mutate
and change there they are worried and
that's why they're saying we need to be
prepared and proactive and take kind of
a widespread public health approach
which is what they're doing and and
they've seen this before they've done
this before in SARS and MERS so dr. Tara
Narula thanks
you